[Applause]
[Music]
the last hours have been marked
by
scenes of violence against
police stations but also schools
in America and therefore against the Fund against the
institutions and the Republic and
this is
unjustifiable
[Music]
[Applause  ]
he was still a child
he needed his mother
this morning he gave me a big kiss he
told me mom I love you I said take
care of yourself then I love you take
care  here
we go out at the same time he went to
get a McDonald's I went to work
like everyone else
1 hour later we say what we shot at my
son
I'm going to do what was my life
he was my best friend c  he was my
son he was my he was everything to me
[Music]